honestly
you've been doing an amazing job in this
space one of the reasons i'm super
excited to do this podcast again
is that um i've learned some things
about what i don't do well
and i also have sort of struggled with
the question should i do those things
better
because what if it's you know i always
use the same example of the fitted sheet
when you're trying to put a queen-size
fitted sheet on a king-sized mattress
he's like okay i got that corner squared
away and then you get another corner
that pops off and they have to go back
around
i wonder whether i can improve my style
in the ways in which
you know i think it's just a recognition
of a difference you do a better job of
getting to the soul
of a really top intellectual guest
and making them accessible and
presenting them as
themselves for a huge number of people
and i'd give my eye tooth to be able to
do that
do you ever think about this like
because i
think about what is the greatest
conversation i'll ever have
you know like in in a sense the portal
not to reduce it to anything but there
will be the greatest conversation
you may have already had it but it's
very possible if if
if enough people like me can keep
twisting your arm to keep doing the
portal please
that is there'll be an amazing
conversation one of the questions
that i ask myself is like who is the
person
that i'm especially equipped for some
reason i'm convinced on putin
there's something in my head that says i
i can do this man
better than anyone else in this world i
got this thought in my head about it i
don't know why
and i'm convinced but i think the
universe works in that way like if it
tells you it's gonna happen the way i
would say it is is that almost everybody
who becomes a supreme court justice
believes at a very early age they're
going to become a supreme court justice
many people believe at an early age that
they can do it don't get there
but of those who get there almost all of
them had this sort of
well i call it pathological
self-confidence
and i do think you have pathological
self-confidence and you also have
humility
and most people would hear those as a
contradiction
i think that you would not be able to
get away with what you do
if you didn't have the humility and so i
think
you know the great danger is that your
equation becomes unbalanced
that you either lose the humility or you
lose the the humility overwhelms
the ego and the drive because right now
you've got a mexican standoff in your
mind and
the rest of us are just benefiting
that's beautifully put my mexican
standoffs aren't as stable as yours
it's all reservoir dogs all the time
yeah but
um actually the person who that
describes is peter thiel peter thiel
thinks more dif people always say like
what does peter think about x y and z p
and q it's like well do you want
communist peter do you want hyper
capitalist peter
in there oh my god right on everything
that's why he's successful is that he's
got all these minds fighting each other
and so when people say peter is this
repeater is that i just laugh
because it like nobody who knows him
would describe him as having
thoughts at the level that people are
claiming and i do think that you know
in my case
um you know there's also pathological
epistemic humility
like just i know i know how little
i know how little i can do in one life i
know how many things i've screwed up
i know how many things i've got wrong
and on
the other hand i know that if if not you
know it's like hillel's questions
you know if i'm not for myself who will
be for me if i'm only for myself what am
i
if not now when you know at some level
there's a question about
if i don't decide that someone is
capable and that somebody is me
and i if i apply that to everyone else
on the planet
then nobody's going to do anything and
so i do think that one of the things
that people like you and i get
is who are you to say that right
f that man just
sign me up for some dunning krueger
yeah but it's multiple minds like you
said like this morning
i was feeling so good and confident
about i couldn't think no wrong
and i remember last night clearly
thinking that i'm the dumbest human
who's ever lived
yeah and nothing i've ever said is worth
anything
and what the [ __ ] am i doing with my
life why am i
scared i was terrified of this
conversation
who the hell is my conversation because
i'm an idiot and because
you know i lex
but no no but this morning
[Laughter]
i was the baddest [ __ ] who's
ever walked this earth so it was
i was very conscious i think it was the
coffee i'm not sure maybe some sleep
this sounds very russian and it involves
multiple beverages some of them being
alcoholic others containing caffeine
there's in fact i can't share the story
behind it but there is a bottle of vodka
in the fridge
okay so i mean i should have hate you
for coffee because this is a morning
there's a morning show here
you